And in Western culture,
the idea there is that do unto others as you would have them do unto you is the
rule that it's the matter of rule that guides all other rules.
Sort of like the one rainy in the,
in the Lord of the rings.
And so it's this consistent pattern of abstraction of ethical guidelines.
So,
okay,
so well and so that maps onto,
while there's a,
there's a micro,
there's a micro level that you instruct people at and that then there's a more
abstract level that you instruct them at and then there's a more abstract level.
While maybe at that point you can't exactly directly instruct the,
you remember in the Pinocchio Story,
Japan,
Oh sits PANORG or the cricket Jiminny Sits Pinocchio Down and tries to lecture
to him about what the highest level of moral virtual,
yes,
he sounds like a complete fraud.
He sounds like a propaganda artist.
He's a soap box preacher and Pinocchio doesn't understand them at all.
Why has to be acted out now maybe as a parent you can be a model for emulation,
which is,
so you're a model for imitation.
What you say matters,
but it doesn't say as much matter as much as what you do.
Maybe it would if what you said and what you did,
we're the same.
That's the ideal situation,
right?
That's what you want to do.
If you're a parent,
if you say one thing and act differently,
your kids will torture you to death and they're right to do it too because
you're confused and confusing them,
makes them anxious and aggressive and they will go after you.
Consistency,
consistency,
consistency.
And if you can't provide it,
you'll drive them crazy.
So you,
you,
you want to bring your words and your actions into alignment.
Right?
And that's part of the development of wisdom.
So,
okay,
so back to the brain.
Okay.
All right.
So there's the,
there's the motor homunculus.
So now what I want to tell you about that is you just,
just think about what this thing is like.
It's taking a world to park
and it's talking about it.
So that's what a human being is like.
And that,
to me,
that's kind of an image of the mythological hero.
It's the thing that can speak magic words.
And take the world's apart.
Take the world apart.
Now in one of the stories I'm going to tell you today,
which is the story of the Enuma Elish,
which is the oldest written story that we have.
It's a Mesopotamian story,
and it's from the same pool of stories that the creation account in genesis was
extracted.
It isn't obvious what the temporal sequence was,
but imagine there was a pool of stories in the Middle East that were of
indefinite age,
tens of thousands of years,
and it needs of the more developed in a slightly different way.
Although the themes underneath were,
were similar.
There are great parallels between the Mesopotamian creation account and the
first part of the creation account in genesis.
So it was discovered in the late 19 hundreds and Isis just destroyed a,
uh,
a treasure trove of that sort of manuscripts.
So just so you know,
so at Nineveh,
so we can,
we can thank the war in the Middle East for the destruction of a huge,
a huge treasure house of irreplaceable human knowledge.
And a lot of that's happening that's happening very,
very frequently.
It's an absolute bloody disgraceful catastrophe.
So anyway,
so you know that that's the human being,
lips,
tongs,
hands,
and the face.
Your face is also extraordinarily amenable to voluntary manipulation.
So you can learn to move single neurons in the tissue underneath your eyes.
That's how,
that's how high resolution your faces.
And that's partly because it's a broadcast screen,
which is why people are always looking at it.
Right.
And that's why if you watch a movie,
it's always concentrating on people's faces is because they're just broadcasting
what they're broadcasting their stories constantly and we're looking at their
faces.
What are you looking at?
What are your eyes pointing at?
What are you up to?
What's your emotional expression?
What are you going to do next?
What do you think about me?
Where are you going?
And your brought like you find someone who has had too much plastic surgery.
Uncanny because their face is dead because you cannot tell what they're up to
there.
They've got this Zombie like aspect that's terrifying.
And people like that.
Look,
people like that got killed.
That's why we're not like that or they didn't mate.
It's like you want to know what that other person is up to.
And I told you already,
that's how the whites of our eyes evolved,
right?
I don't you remember that story.
Gorillas don't have that distinction between the Iris and the whites,
not like human beings.
And our eyes are very sharp.
And one thing we really want to know is what are you looking at and why?
What are you up to?
And if I can tell what you're looking at,
I can infer what you're going to do and you want to broadcast that.
Well,
except when you don't want to broadcast it.
But you know,
most of the time you want to be pretty transparent to other people because
otherwise they won't trust you.
And if they don't trust you,
they won't cooperate with you,
they won't compete with you.
And the probability that they'll come after you is extraordinarily high cause
you'll be evil Predator in no time flat.
So,
okay,
so we'll take a look at the brain from another perspective.
Now,
a lot of this I got from El Colon Goldberg,
um,
well that's not exactly right.
I had laid a,
laid this out before that,
but I found Elkhorn Goldberg's writings afterwards and he was a student of
lariats and he was trying to account for the y.
We had different hemispheres roughly speaking,
because it's,
it's not self evident that we should,
they're actually somewhat separate consciousnesses and they,
they communicate,
but the communication isn't complete.
It's like our brain is modularized and unified at the same time.
And you can think about it like a meeting of people.
Why do you want it Maude,
Maude muellerized while,
so if one person goes down,
all of them don't.
That's one,
one reason.
So it's some separation of function.
Why else?
Well,
each little module can do its own creative thing independently of the others.
And that's useful.
And then there can be communication between them.
And so there's,
there's utility in modularity and there's utility and integration.
And part of what we're trying to work out on the global political scene right
now is how modular things should be and how integrated they should be.
And the European Community rushed into integration.
And that's bothering people dreadfully because they feel that the advantages of
modularization have been washed away.
You saw that and maybe they're right because you saw what happened with Greece
collapsed,
right.
And Greece is very,
very corrupt,
incredibly corrupt and Germany,
whatever else you might think about Germany is not corrupt.
And so the Isi tried to bring Greece and Germany together.
That didn't work.
There was no unity there.
The modularity was actually useful and the fact that Greece was so destabilized
and Italy also very corrupt and Spain also very corrupt,
was very shaky just about brought the whole thing down.
It it.
The argument is the modularity would have been better conserved.
Well who knows,
right?
Because modularity is useful and so is integration.
But fall integration seems to be a mistake and so does full modularity.
How do you get that right?
We don't know.
That's why we're arguing about it.
And right now there's a backlash or pulling away from the integration and you
can see why too,
because in 2008 with the American economy collapsed,
the world economy just about collapsed.
That seems like a bad idea.
You know,
you might want some,
some separateness so that if one system malfunctions and goes down,
the whole bloody thing doesn't go into flames.
And so we don't know.
We don't know how to manage that.
It's a really,
really complicated problem.
So anyways.
Okay.
So how did the,
how does the brain work?
Well,
the left roughly speaking in right handed males,
and the reason that I'm concentrating on right hand had males is because they're
simpler in their neurological structure.
Women have a more complicated neurological structure and lefthanded people tend
to have a more complicated neurological structure.
So we'll just say that we'll just go with the standard model to begin with.
And you can assume that the same systems are there in every person,
but they're not laid out on the hemispheric structure quite as neatly,
but they're still there.
So it's sort of like,
these are tendencies.
So for example,
if you're a,
so there's a tendency for the right hemisphere to specialize for what's
relatively unknown and the left hemisphere to specialize for what's relatively
mastered.
And you can think about it this way too,
left,
right?
It's something like that.
Okay.
So
large scale,
low resolution abstractions tend to be the province of the right high
resolution.
Detailed knowledge tend to be the province of the left.
The left is linguistic.
That's where the detailed structures manifest themselves in articulation,
but the fundamental difference between the left and right isn't language versus
non language.
The fundamental distinction is relatively explored and mastered versus
relatively unexplored and not mastered and that's both in terms of structure.
The right hemisphere has a less granular structure,
it's less differentiated.
It's also responsible mostly for negative emotion,
especially in the prefrontal park.
And the reason for that is,
well,
how do you encounter what's absolutely unknown?
Imagination and emotion,
right?
I told you that little experiment that you could do if you're alone in a house
and you hear a strange noise at night in a room,
turn off the lights and put your hand in the room.
It's like your brain will just flash off monsters like mad.
You know,
you'll be nervous cause that what's in that room.
Something to make you nervous.
That's a very low resolution category,
right?
It's like it's a,
it's some indeterminate manifestation of the category of things that might hurt
you.
Very low resolution,
but a very smart category.
It's like don't put your hand in there.
You put your hand in there and you watch your imagination.
It's like monsters.
It'll generate monsters like Matt and that's what the right hemisphere is doing.
It's saying what's in there is an exemplar of the category of things that are
dangerous.
Here's a bunch of images of those things and that thing in there is going to
partake of that essence.
And that's a very low resolution hypothesis.
That's kind of what horror movies do with people.
You know,
they sort of lead them through that initial process and so and so that's what
the right,
the right hemisphere seems to me to be dominated by dominated by subcortical
processes.
There's the left hemisphere is reversed,
the cortex is more or less got dominion.
And so the right hemisphere,
while we'll walk through this neurologically,
but the right hemisphere is responds rapidly to what's unknown.
And that's that subcortical that the hippocampus is,
is doing an awful lot of that noting a mismatch.
And then it's using the right hemisphere to,
to abstractly represent what the possibility space is in relationship down
expected things.
And then the right hemisphere is tracking that continually,
what those unexpected things are and coming up with models of what you haven't
yet mastered.
And that's kept separate from the left hemisphere,
which already has functional models and you don't want to blast the left
hemisphere continually with enormous information cause you blow out its
structure and then you don't know what to do.
So the right hemisphere generates new models in some sense out of nothing.
And then when the time is right,
taps information into the left hemisphere slowly so that it doesn't disrupt its
function too much.
And that's a lot of that seems to happen when you're dreaming by the way it
happens at night.
So in what happens with the dreams,
you think about how dreams work,
cause you might think of dreams as part of that process where ideas come to be.
So they're low resolution to begin with.
Mostly a majestic,
really highly emotional and incoherent,
less coherent.
Why you can't be coherent unless you know what to do.
f if that's working,
you've got coherence.
But if you're dealing with something you don't know,
you have to muck about with your category structures.
And that's what dreams do.
And you know,
when you're interpreting a dream,
one of the things you watch for is the dream.
The dream presents this.
And then this.
That's called metonymy.
By the way,
from a literary perspective,
and what that implies is this is related to this in some way.
Why else would they be code activated?
You know,
people say,
well,
dreams are random.
That's the stupidest theory I've ever heard.
Like white noise is random.
Dreams are not random.
They're hard to understand,
but they're anything but random.
There are more random than real life.
Well,
that's because what you don't understand these really random and you're
organized and there has to be an intermediary that's sort of quasi random
between the more you never get from one to the other,
and dreams and fantasies,
myths,
all of that is part of that process that it stretches you out beyond what you
know,
into the absolute unknown.